[Music]
on this Monday night signs a Gaza
hostage deal is close as families of the
captives clash with far-right lawmakers
who want Hamas militants
executed and newborns evacuated from
Gaza get a chance at life give them
shelter a preview of the federal plan
for affordable
housing open Revolt at open AI why the
CEO was ousted and hundreds of employees
are threatening to quit and New
Brunswick's new rock stars and I thought
it was a joke the astronomical feat of
three amateur
astronomers global national with Donna
freezen good evening and thanks for
joining us there appears to be progress
on the release of some of the hostages
in Gaza American President Joe Biden
said today he believes a deal brokered
by the US uncut is close it's thought to
involve about 50 hostages and a limited
pause in fighting to allow humanitarian
Aid in there's also some good news about
28 premature babies in intensive care in
Gaza they are now in Egypt after being
loaded into Mobile incubators and
ambulances at the Rafa crossing the who
says 11 of them are in critical
condition five others died before they
could make the journey the evacuation
was risky an air strike on the southern
city of hanun has killed multiple people
people and there are reports Israeli
forces are closing in on another
hospital the Indonesian hospital where
gaza's Health Ministry says at least 12
people were killed by Israeli shelling
Israel captured a number of Hamas
Fighters after the October 7th attack
and there's an intense debate underway
over what to do with them far-right
politicians want to use the death
penalty and have them executed relatives
of some of the hostages are deeply
opposed to that Mike Armstrong on how
the hostage crisis is exposing deep
divisions in Israel and a warning some
of the images in the story are
distressing this was not how things were
supposed to go families of the hostages
have for weeks called for a voice at the
table with
lawmakers well voices were
raised Linda Dan Calderone has three
family members believed to be held by
Hamas she says some in the government
are more focused on Revenge than getting
hostages back with every day that passes
there are new videos of the horrors of
October 7th This One released Monday
shows Hamas Fighters chasing and
executing civilians one thing the videos
have done is ratchet up the
anger now on that day Israel captured
about 200 Hamas Fighters The Burning
question now is what to do with
them well the far right national
security minister wants those prisoners
tried and
executed edir benir told the families
the death penalty is a must to prevent
another Massacre another disaster he
says yarden gan's sister is believed to
be a hostage she says the time to debate
the death penalty will come but it's not
now the fear for some of the families
that talk of capital punishment could
provoke
retaliation at a time when their loved
ones are still in the hands of Hamas
adalan is one of those who had eluded
Justice for 15 years now Israel does
have the death penalty on the books but
it hasn't been used in more than six
decades the last time was German Nazi
Adolf ikan hanged in
1962 even if in the past we did
something to Min she says we're not a
Revenge seeking
Nation now Israel has also captured
about 300 Hamas Fighters during its
ground
offensive Israeli Defense Forces say
interrogations with those prisoners have
helped expose Hamas operations and
confirmed targets but those are
prisoners Israel will have to deal with
as well now for many of the families
what makes talk of executions
particularly painful at this point is
the timing it comes as there is finally
hope of deal that could lead to the
release of some of the hostages Donna
all right Mike Armstrong in Jerusalem
tonight thanks today the UN Secretary
General said the world is witnessing the
killing of civilians in Gaza that is
unparalleled and unprecedented he said
in any conflict since he took office
according to gaza's health Ministry more
than 13,000 people have been killed more
than 5,500 of them children and of the
2.3 million people in Gaza the UN says
1.7 million have now been displaced from
their homes a group of Canadian MPS has
arrived in Israel as part of what they
call a bipartisan trip to show
solidarity with the country two liberals
and three conservatives are among a
larger delegation that includes Canadian
Jewish leaders they'll be meeting with
some of their Israeli counterparts and
survivors of the October 7th
attacks not all of those killed and
taken hostage on October 7th were
Israeli migrant workers from Thailand
were victims too caught in a massacre
that has nothing to do with them their
story coming up a little later the
American defense secretary announced
$100 million in new military aid for
Ukraine today during an unannounced
visit to
keev we welome Lloyd Austin told
Ukrainian President Vladimir zalinski
Ukraine's effort to defeat Russia
matters to the rest of the world the US
has provided $44 billion dollar in
security Aid since that War Began 21
months ago there is drama unfolding at
the company which created chat GPT
employees at open AI are in open Revolt
Microsoft has hired the company's former
CEO Sam Alton and now 500 employees of
open AI are threatening to quit Eric
Sorenson explains fast-moving events at
one of silicon Valley's top
companies for a company pioneering
artificial intelligence it seems genuine
human bungling can still occur if this
technology goes wrong it can go quite
wrong Sam Alman as much as anyone the
human face on artificial intelligence
was fired by open ai's nonprofit board
the reason given he was not consistently
candid in his Communications with the
board but there has been growing tension
at open AI between its mandate to
benefit humanity and its move to
commercialize what it's doing as
intelligence gets integrated everywhere
we will all have superpowers on demand
they haven't said specifically that it
was about Sam moving too fast to
commercialize this stuff but that's the
sense that that I think a lot of people
are getting no sooner had open ai's
board ousted Altman then another
co-founder Greg Brockman quit almost as
quickly open AI tried to reinstate
Altman but he and Brockman were already
being hired by Microsoft open ai's
largest investor to head up a new AI
team now open AI has appointed EMT Shear
formerly of twitch as interim CEO he
says he will hire an independent
investigator to look into what the board
has done dig into the entire process and
generate a full report most of open ai's
700 employees had threatened to quit if
Alman wasn't reinstated could many now
follow him to Microsoft could it be the
end of open AI what we saw over the
weekend is it's not the company that
creates technology it is the people and
talent is fluid Microsoft CEO SATA
Nadella was on stage with Altman just
two weeks ago how is Microsoft thinking
about the partnership currently
first we love you guys I think satin
nadell has has played a very strong hand
you know incredibly well and
and right now it seems like he's going
to sort of acquire most of the company
and it it feels very much like Microsoft
is come out the winner here experts say
in the big picture the public must
engage with how to deal with AI in our
lives a lot of conversations are
happening around the world including in
Canada on how to govern this technology
artificial intelligence is coming and
with humans involved it could be a bumpy
ride Eric senson Global News
Toronto there is a troubling indicator
about global warming preliminary data
shows the Earth has breached a critical
temperature threshold for the first time
in recorded history on Friday according
to Europe's Cernic's climate monitor the
global average temperature was more than
2 degrees higher than pre-industrial Lev
levels it happened on Saturday too the
data surpasses the limits set out in the
Paris climate Accord in 2015 that's when
global leaders agreed to work towards
capping the rise of global temperatures
at 1.5° above pre-industrial Ral levels
as Jackson prco reports carbon cutting
policies haven't done enough to reduce
emissions though it's still only spring
in Brazil temperatures have already
outpaced the depths of Summer the heat
index reached 58 deges C in Rio Saturday
pushing the limits of
survival The Future Has Arrived said
this local climate expert we will
collect what we SED for decades of
negligence Planet wide temperatures are
obliterating records scientists confirm
Earth briefly surpassed the 2 degree
warming limit set out in the Paris
climate Accord part of a disturbing
long-term Trend the temperature we are
experiencing in these days are
unprecedented in in our civilization in
the last thousands in hundred of
thousand of
years temperature is just part of the
story floods droughts and fires have all
been supercharged by climate change yet
countries are missing their emission
targets the world's fossil fuel
producers are planning a massive
increase in production blowing past the
world's carbon budget twice over at a
time when they should be cutting
emissions the emissions Gap is more like
an emissions Canyon a canyon LED with
broken promises broken lives and broken
records without drastic changes the UN
warns the world is firmly on track to
see 3° in warming by the end of the
century a catastrophic point of no
return threatening the future of
humanity we will see maybe 10 times as
many uh extreme weather events we're
also risking that large parts of the
world might become uninhabitable these
dire warnings come just a week before
the cop 28 climate conference where
world leaders will be urged to strike a
drastic New Deal on emissions to keep
the global average temperature from
Rising by more than 2 degre C the UN
warns that countries will need to slash
emissions by 28% before the end of this
decade Jackson prco Global News
Washington Federal Finance Minister
chrisa Freeland will present Canada's
fall economic update tomorrow it's
expected to make billions of dollars in
loans available for home building and
establish a fund to build more
affordable housing Mercedes Stevenson is
with me from Ottawa Mercedes what more
do you know Donna a senior government
Source says this update will be focused
on two main themes housing and
affordability both have been major
challenges for the government in policy
and perhaps even more so in the polls
tomorrow the Liberals will announce
three significant measures aimed at
creating more housing and helping to
keep people in their homes the first
measure is a carrot for the construction
industry to build more homes the
government will announce $15 billion in
loans issued directly from the cmhc to
builders that money will result in the
construction of approximately 30,000
Apartments according to my source the
next measure is a stick designed to
crack down on short-term rentals like
airbnbs the tax department will no
longer allow Canadians to write off
their short-term rental property
expenses if the owner lives in a
municipality or a province that bans
them or if they're not up to date on
their certifications and Licensing this
could create a steep income tax penalty
and encourage returning these homes to
the long-term rental market the final
measure is essentially a mortgage
holders Charter of Rights it will allow
homeowners to temporarily amortize their
mortgage over a longer period and to
avoid penalties for delayed payments in
some situations financial institutions
will also have to warn mortgage holders
6 months before their renewal so they
can comparison shop and if they find a
better deal with another lender they
won't have to pass a stress test to
change Banks Donna all right Mercedes
Stevenson in Ottawa thanks they were in
Israel working hard to send money home
coming up the migrant workers from
Thailand Hill captive and caught in
Israel's war on
Hamas
those taken hostage in Gaza are into
their 45th day in captivity the Hamas
attacks on October 7th targeted Israeli
communities but more than 20 Thai
Nationals are believed to be held
hostage 32 other Thai citizens are
thought to have been killed they were
among thousands of Thai Nationals
working on Israeli Farms along the
border with Gaza Danielle Hamin reports
on the victims caught in the conflict
between Hamas and Israel and a warning
the images in her story are
graphic the harvest season is over and
all 13 men who worked on this Vineyard
in Southwest Israel before October 7th
remain
today even when 7,000 agricultural
workers chose to return to
Thailand like everyone else who lives
and works in this country they know what
to do when the aate siren goes
off
we would do exactly what they did he
tells us we would run to the safe room
the entrance to the thae worker safe
room in kibuts near o feels like a
moment Frozen in time while Hamas
militants went on a rampage some of the
workers sought Refuge here but instead
they were slaughtered one look inside
and no description of the massacre that
unfolded is
needed 16 men used to live and earn a
living on this kibuts working the fields
and sending money to family back home
five of them are unaccounted for the
rest are confirmed dead there's not an
inch here that hasn't been ransacked or
destroyed behind me one of the
bedrooms it's covered in blood and you
can still smell after a whole month the
stench of
death there was nowhere to hide and
there was no mercy sh shown to
foreigners dozens of th men were killed
that day along with other foreign
laborers as for those missing Thai
officials have been given no proof of
Life all they know is what they've seen
in photos and
videos and based on that they believe 25
are being held captive by Hamas in
Gaza we do hope that the first group of
Hostage should be should have some TI
people
it's believed that Tha Nationals make up
the second largest group of hostages
after Israelis how do you explain what
happened to the Thai workers given that
they have absolutely nothing to do with
the Israeli Palestinian conflict that's
what we don't understand as well you
know the Tai people they came here to
work in the farm in in agricultural
sector officials in Thailand say they've
held direct talks with Hamas in Iran
bypassing Israel and have been told Tha
hostages would be released at the right
time as Israel's war against Hamas rages
on when the right time could be is
anyone's
guess Danielle Haman Jin Global News in
kibuts near
o still ahead India's latest strategy to
reach workers trapped in a
[Music]
tunnel
41 construction workers in India are
entering their 10th day trapped inside a
tunnel part of it collapsed and they're
stuck behind more than 50 MERS of rock
there is a huge operation to try to
reach them but it's been plagued by
equipment failur and fears of a new
collapse Redmond Shannon explains why
rescue teams have gone back to the
drawing
board after more than a week of failed
rescue attempts at the highway tunnel
project some good news on Monday even if
it's not the good news that the families
of the 41 trapped construction workers
have been waiting
for this Indian official said a 15 cm
wide pipe has broken through to reach
the men allowing Rescuers to send in hot
food before now a smaller pipe was used
to deliver dry food water and oxygen the
road tunnel is in a region of the lower
Himalayas the workers are stuck behind
about 53 M of rock that collapsed into
the tunnel not far from the southern
entrance on Friday teams suspended
efforts to dig horizontally over fears
of another collapse now Engineers have a
brand new plan to dig down vertically
from the
hilltop first they need to build a road
to get the drills directly above the
tunnel this International tunneling
expert has arrived as part consultant
part cheerleader we're going to get
those men now what I've seen seriously
what I've seen there are great great
works being done this this is going to
happen some residents have reportedly
blamed the collapse on the wrath of a
local deity after a temple was moved to
make way for the highway
tunnel others are angry that politicians
broke their promises about the rescue
timeline as for how long it takes
everyone here agrees we want the men out
safe and The Rescuers safe and that's as
that's as long as it
takes just like the Chilean miners
rescue in 2010 teams aim to dig multiple
tunnels at once to increase their
chances this dig is much shallower than
Chile about 100 m down rather than 700
but in a region prone to landslides some
Divine forgiveness sure wouldn't go
astray Redmond Channon Global News
London next the New Brunswick amateur
astronomers who just got an out of this
world
[Music]
honor most people take on a hobby
because they love it not because it's
going to lead to something big well
three amateur astronomers from the
maritimes are celebrating something big
an asteroid has been named after them
not because they discovered it but
because of their shared passion for
astronomy Heidi petruk introduces us to
the new rock stars and I thought it was
a joke three new brunswickers passionate
about astronomy now have an asteroid
more than 550 million kilometers away
named after them we would never have
dreamt it never their particular Rock
once only known as Number
220 now called me pack for Mike Paul and
Chris I wasn't expecting that from my
hobby in any way shape manner or form to
see their asteroid you would need a
telescope like this one at the Burke
Gaffney observatory in Halifax's St
Mary's University because these minor
planets as they're known are relatively
small dim and difficult to make out the
tradition going back 200 years is that
asteroids are named by their discoverers
but modern technology means scientists
detect many more asteroids in space
these days far too many to name
themselves so organizations like the
Royal Astronomical Society of Canada
submit nominations from local clubs and
so their Club nominated the three of
them for the work they've been
doing just before the covid-19 pandemic
is when the trio launched their own
weekly Show online encouraging others to
gaze towards the stars with them I
always say we're all looking at the same
Moon so um you no matter where you are
in the world so now their names are
recorded forever in astronomical history
who's get the mineral rights that's what
I want to know
even as their feet are planted firmly on
the ground Heidi petruk Global News
hellofax love those guys and that is
global national for this Monday I'm
Donna FZ tonight's your Canada is
Montreal where the alets are celebrating
their first gray cup win since 2010 they
pulled off a last minute comeback to
upset the Winnipeg Blue Bombers in
Canada's biggest football game of the
year sorry Winnipeg thanks for watching
I'll see you again on Wednesday
bye-bye
[Music]